yeah cooking knows you got a crooked
nose and one of your ears is shorter
than the other
you got a crooked nose one of your ears
are shorter than the other and your top
lip is stupid
you got a crooked nose one of your ears
are short in the other and your top lip
is stupid and on top of that your
hairline it's [ __ ] up
you got a crooked nose one of your ears
out there your top lip stupid your hair
last [ __ ] up your eyes down
you got a crooked you got a crooked lip
your eyes is [ __ ] up one of your ears
is tall and then the thing is done
you got a crooked nose when your ears is
[ __ ] up you top with a stupid your
hairline is [ __ ] up and one of my ears
is done and your skin complexion makes
my balls itch you got a crooked nose
when he is is [ __ ] up your hairline is
[ __ ] up your lip is crooked your eye
went down any balls
it's dark in the mic yeah so I won well
you definitely lost it's safe to say you
lost I lost I lost all right so you
gotta hear me phone let me send out a
tweet from your phone all right now
Kevin Hart I lost a game and he's gonna
actually tweet something for my phone he
didn't write a ham look in trouble yeah
here at lunch I baked let me see here
make sure this sounds the way I wanted
to sound how lucky am i I get to work
with the amazing that Kevin Hart
Pharrell every day
God is so good to me oh how funny he is
[Music]
[Laughter]
great that's a good one right yeah
should I buckle up Wally here it's
abundance of love that I'm gonna get
right now tweet I'm gonna Wow
ha